Ooh, what? Cuz you would just look at Crystal with a silly face
and be like, "What the [__] are you talking
>> When I make these silly faces at you, I am saying you're
I am saying you for asking me this question. I am saying you
stupid piece of [__] Banana, banana, banana, banana,
stop, stop, stop, stop. You got to stop. Stop.
All right, we're we're going to live and learn stuff real quick.
>> We all agree there's a lot less tolerance for scandal
among Democrats and that >> Unless your name is Platner,
Gran Platner. He's [laughter] he's literally like the only one.
He's like a [__] unicorn. Everybody else gets like
shoved out of the party, but for some reason like he is quite
>> Yeah, I got to ask in this room because you know, I
I'm I feel like I'm separated from most of the Twitch pulse base
now cuz I kind of you know, I I not separated completely, but
I'm kind of like in this you know, in this bubble away from it.
So, I like coming back >> we're all but off online. We
got it doing here. You're cool. >> be clear I cough over
here, too, but what's important, I just want to know, do you
guys like private Toden cough? Like what's the position here?
>> We I've endorsed him and I don't like him. >> Wait,
should we react Is Dylan going to make an argument that if somebody
has something that could be you know, appear to be a Nazi symbol,
you should in a totally reactive way refuse to support or endorse
them? Cuz that seems like a really dangerous line for Dylan of
all people to start crossing, no? Feels like a really strange
line for him to go to. It'd be
"Listen, Nazi symbols, well, that's that's a hard red line for
me."
>> Hey, hey, hey. >> I don't I think that I I I don't
trust
I think that he is just telling people a lot of stuff they want
to hear, but in my view he is so much more likely to win, significantly
more likely to win than Janet Mills
that's just the way the cookie crumbles. He's a bandwagon fan.
I'm a Janet Mills stan, dude. I'm I'm not afraid to say it. I
think she's got the juice. I think
ready to start a new career at 78 years old and
>> I'm excited to see what she does.
That's the least shocking thing I've
ever heard. All right, he's a He's joining the Mills militia.
That's That's the least shocking thing I've ever heard in my
>> first term. But no, I I think she's won statewide. She's
a well-known
person, you know, there's a lot of risk with Platner. I said
it last time. People don't want another Fetterman and I think
there's a lot of concern that he could turn out to be like Fetterman.
>> Yeah, I'm hesitant of Platner. I like some of his more
progressive policies, but just like shown too many like character
flaws for me to be like, yeah, I trust this person in office
and Mills >> Is there a character flaw outside of the
Is it the Reddit posts where he says he signed up to kill people?
>> People [laughter] act like Mills is some like ancient
evil and you look at her record and it's like this is pretty
damn good. Like I totally >> She's canceling debates.
>> She would be like one of the oldest
Um and and she's pulling like 40 points below. So here's the
problem, right? Like I understand all the hesitancy with Platner.
Trust me, I I do get it and >> Why Why are the liberals
even running somebody who's 78?
Why Why do that? Honestly, honest to God, I feel like if Grant
Platner was so for real, he would just say, "My opponent is 78
years old. Don't vote for her."
"My opponent is 78 years old."
Why the [__] are you running a
Dude, what? >> And maybe he'll prove us us wrong, including
myself, in that I don't trust him and people I think have good
reason not to trust aspects of him. But we are in a moment in
which people are tired of the old guard Democrat and that includes
both biologically old but also the old guard as viewed in the
establishment. The overall approval rating among Democrats for
their leaders in Congress is net negative at least one poll that
I saw recently and that's not to say that Democrats aren't obviously
way better but but that is a reflection of internal Democratic
angst at the leadership of the party and it's not just lefties,
tankies, socialists, whatever you want to say it. These are rank
and file Democrats. >> I've taken a lot of heat on this
podcast because I've taken a very maximalist
blue no matter who position. I'll give honest answers to insane
thought experiments like would you vote for Hitler or you know
Hasan [__] This is like a perfect opportunity for
me to demonstrate that because like I don't like Platner. I am
worried about him like on a debate stage with Susan Collins who's
like a very capable politician but I view him as inevitable.
I can see the numbers just like everybody else and Mills is she's
just only gone down. And he started with a pretty decent lead
on her. So I just view him as inevitable and as such
you [snorts] know, I have no problems with Grant Platner. I've
always liked him. I'm not concerned at all. >> No no problems.
>> Not a single one. >> And he has not a single >> He
has no problem he's never had with Grant Platner. >> He
has my earnest and sincere
endorsement and I would have encouraged anybody who lives in
Maine to vote for him too. >> Okay listen to me
>> Let's go. I mean is that Hutch saying he supports Platner
over Mills?
Didn't expect that to be honest.
I think that's something that's like so disconnected by the way.
When people say it all that matters is policies.
Right? It's like no how these people talk like what they sound
like how engaging they
It matters. It really does matter and Platner is a good speaker.
Platner is very good. He's very believable. Right? Guy used to
be a bartender and it kind of shows a little bit. Did Hutch manage
to have the worst takes and still land on Platner? I don't know.
I don't know.
The Totenkopf thing I I believe is real, Pumpernickel. The And
And it was like a legit Totenkopf. It was not like a fake Totenkopf.
It was
So, it's it's like real. It was there.
He says he got it while he was drunk and he didn't realize what
it was. I do tend to think that he might not have known the extent
to which it was a Nazi symbol. But, he probably had some idea
it was like Like the guys who would have gone and gotten it with
him. Somebody there knew what it was precisely. And somebody
Like somebody Something happened where he's been told about this
in his life. The idea that he's gone his whole life to swimming
pools, to beaches, to Like random women or his wife, whoever.
Somebody told him, "Hey, that's like a Nazi symbol. Don't you
know that?"
Somebody somewhere said, "Hey, that's weird. Why do you have
a white nationalist like Nazi symbol on your
Not white national Well, white nationalists get it now.
And then he lied about it, right? I think I think probably he
had this lie he was telling people
and thought it just wouldn't come up. And then footage came out
showing the tattoo and it's like, "Oh, now it's come up." And
so, he does the same lie. He gets it removed. I don't think he's
like some sort of ideological Nazi white supremacist anything
along these lines. I really don't. It's just goofy
to think so. Like he wouldn't be running with these policies.
He wouldn't be running the way he is.
But, like he definitely had the symbol and it it It's like one
of those things where it's like I think if you admit it, you
do have to drop out of the race. And so, he's like lying in a
way that he thinks it's like a a like a lie of omission that's
less harmful than him dropping out of the race. Maybe.
That's about it. Could have changed his mind? I didn't get the
impression he I didn't get the impression he was like some sort
of like anti-Semite or something either. From the Reddit posts.
I went and looked at the Reddit posts before, too.
Sparks, can I just say one thing before we get into it? I do
want to let you in because you guys dealt with a lot of this
in the Ukrainian funding stuff with Azov Battalion all this stuff
and I'm sure that there are some I want to talk about that. >> to
say. That's the first thing I was going to say. It's fascinating
to watch all of the people who said we can't support Ukraine
because of Azov now come out and say that, you know, a black
>> Who said this? Wait, did somebody say we can't sup First
of all, point me at the people who said we can't support Ukraine
because of Azov because that from the very beginning was totally
moronic.
But who who are we even calling out here? Is this like somebody
made up? Who Who made this up?
Yeah, I realize there's a huge Russian talking point that like
everybody pointed out was obviously just coming from Russians
like Russian shills, total Russian stooges. Like no serious political
actor. It's like, dude, Jackson Hinkle? Like Jackson Hinkle by
himself out here? >> quarter mercenary
>> Gabbriana Joy Gray is not in the coalition. Not because
anything but just I've seen her say some of the dumbest [__]
imaginable, okay? >> I saw that growing on Reddit that
>> Not a fan of Breezy. I'm saying it now. If you guys
love Breezy, you're not going to love me, okay? I'm not a fan
of >> And if he could fight in any war in America's history,
he'd like to go kill the Native Americans
>> who who
Like I can't say that. >> He didn't say exactly like that.
He he's he chose that war but yes, that's right. >> he
wanted to fight Yeah, he said he wanted to fight in the Indian
Wars, not one said the Indian Wars which by the way has an S
at the end of it. I just want to throw that out there, okay?
So, I would say that person
>> What if he just loved like Red Dead Redemption? He just
wants to be a
Can't be on the Indian side cuz he's not Indian. So, he's he
wants to be a cowboy. Is that really that bad to romanticize
being a cow Come on, man. >> with a SS tattoo on his chest
and I still don't accept anybody who tells me, "Oh, he had no
clue what that was." He's on Reddit debating whether or not soldiers
can have those types of tattoos. He knows what the [__]
tattoo is, right?
I I see all that and then I see his biggest advocates in some
circles are many of the same people who were scoffing at the
idea of supporting Ukraine because of the Azov Battalion and
their symbology >> Burns, I'm consistent. I I wanted to
support Ukraine and I wanted to support all the the fight against
Russia and >> Yeah, I just I I feel like I would love to
know is there like a big influencer who said this? Who tried
to go in this >> I'm willing to, you know, to to do the
lesser evil here when it comes to when it comes to Susan Collins.
So, yeah, I understand the critique and you know what? You're
right. And if >> It's not It's not a critique. I just find
it funny. >> It's not a critique. I just find it funny.
It's not I just find it funny. That's it. >> Well, Pisco,
would you say maybe when he said he wants to fight in the Native
American wars like he was just showing that he probably had the
highest survival rate cuz they didn't have guns, right? So, he
was just saying like >> They had guns. Well, not as many.
>> Like they they they had a technological disadvantage
and he was just like, well, I'll pick the one where I'm probably
going to live. >> Oh, you mean the >> Probably had
nothing to do with No, I I think that Listen, I I don't get the
impression that the
>> You want to know what that really is? I like maybe maybe
there's a reason to totally disqualify him as a candidate.
I think he he seemed like somebody who
is like Spartan in like a true sense. Isn't like He just wanted
to be in combat with people and I feel like for the Indian wars
he chose that cuz of the brutality that was enabled.
Like he would just literally Like, "Hey, they're scalping us.
Listen,
Let's go. I can do whatever I want." I feel like honest to God
that sounds like given the other things said that that might
be the reason he chose that. >> Uh actually what I was
going to say about Slotkin is I mean regardless of what you think
of her politics, watching her under fire on Breaking Points like
I thought that was a very dismal performance from her like and
>> I I this is a Rorschach test. I I think you should watch
it again and just >> I love that Hutch calls it a Rorschach
test cuz it totally is. It's just not the test he thinks it is.
>> Go into it with be open to a different interpretation
because I actually rewatched that I watched it at the time and
I had the same reaction that I did the last time I watched it
which is a few days ago just to like remember what that was about.
I think in that moment she is a
who feels a bit of contempt and frustration that she has to like
talk to >> Oh, that's No, that's my thing. >> That's
why I said regardless of your politics, I just think optically
it still looked bad. Like I don't think she
I You know, I've never watched that.
I don't think that's a good attitude to By the way, that is the
precise essence that Third Way and every single other Democrat
consulting group says is the cancer of the Democratic Party,
right? This is what kills Democrats when you look like an arrogant
piece of sh that destroys you. You cannot come back from that.
You cannot look like an arrogant piece of sh you will lose. You
will lose. You will lose. So stop looking like and acting like
arrogant pieces of sh. It's super easy to >> I think it
is bad. Like I don't think she handled that well. If you agree
with her, I don't think she handled it well. If you disagree
with her. Like I think that is not
what you're If you're going to be under fire running for president,
I think it's
just not a good look if that's how you handle adversary. And
if you like compare that to like I don't know Bill Clinton on
like Fox News.
I just don't think she had good responses. And I agree I I really
don't like Crystal Ball and on a lot of issues. So I'm not like
saying this as like a a Crystal Ball breaking points fan. So
>> I could not disagree more. Like I felt
I felt like she was remarkably composed. There were there was
really only one moment where she let the guard down >> Dude,
dude, Hutch How does Hutch think she was remarkably composed?
Cuz I've not seen this interview and somebody linked me it as
I've not seen it, but I don't know a single person who thought
she handled it well, except for Hutch. Hutch is like literally
the only person in the world I've ever heard say this. It's like
what Soy Pill is saying. It's more of like even if you agree
with her and and hate Breaking Points,
she got like kind of rolled, and she had no way to deal with
it, and she looks really bad.
Yeah, it's like like he's somehow taking a position here that
seems
that I really wish I'd watch the interview now. Uh maybe we'll
pull it up.
One more one more dumb comment from Hutch. I'll just pull the
interview up,
It's literally for like a >> Let's keep going. >> half
a second where she gave Crystal kind of like a sideways glance,
literally like a sideways glance. But, they were pressing her
and asking her questions,
and she was answering their questions, and then basically every
time she started to answer their questions, they would cut her
off, not address what she had just said, and then deflect to
some other question. And some of the questions that they were
asking her, I'm sorry, were ridiculous.
>> Okay, hold on. I do think Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Would they So, I really hope the case isn't going to be that
when we pull up this interview, I hope that it's not going to
be Crystal Ball asking a question, Alyssa Slotkin totally dodging
not answering the question at all, and Crystal trying to go,
"Well, actually my question was
If that's if if Hutch is describing it what I what I just said,
if he's describing what I just said, in the way he's describing
it now, as if that's like it actually they were just being rude
to her, they weren't trying to keep her on track. I really really
really hope that Hutch isn't like just lying to me. We'll see.
>> Like this gotcha question that Crystal asked, where
she said, "Oh, you support, you know, providing Iron Dome to
Israel? Why wouldn't you also support giving it to Iran and Russia
to help protect their civilians?" As if they're
>> Let's see. Let's see how people deal with Hutch saying
this. >> There's not like five immediate
for why we would never give Iran and Russia on the I >> I
thought Well, I thought it was just to protect civilians. If
it's only to protect civilians, why wouldn't you do Don't you
care about civilian life even if it's for your like people who
are your adversaries? It's going to You you will have to go into
This question exposes
why
providing the Iron Dome to Israel is actually enabling and abetting
their offensive capability. Right? It allows them to ignore the
downsides, the responses to their actions in the region. And
so, obviously, you would never give it to your enemies because
then your enemies are more free to just attack whoever they want.
That's the point of the question. >> All right. But you're
attacking >> Is the question unfair? Wait, is Is the question
unfair or is you just disagree >> is [__]
In virtue of what is it ridiculous? >> You tell me. Peace
go. Can you think of way we wouldn't give Iran and Russia the
Iron Dome? >> Uh 100%, but are you just saying that the
the question is unfair because it's obvious what the answer is
and so you shouldn't ask. >> I didn't say I said it's a
silly >> I said it's a silly question. It's a really really
really profoundly silly >> way she answered the silly question
was not nearly so optically good as she could have. Like like
it looked like she's on the back foot where the answer should
be nearly so optically good as she could have.
like it looks like she's on the back foot. >> Awesome.
Just awesome. >> answer should be a simple like, "Hey,
we have allies and we have adversaries." And I I I'm just saying
I I'm not so confident that she could perform well on a presidential
>> So So, is that a layup question then, Hutch, if it's
so obvious? >> It's Well, it's a layup if you're not a
politician and you don't need to worry about being composed cuz
you would just look at Crystal with a silly face and be like,
"What the [__] are you talking?"
>> No shot. No shot Hutch just said, "When When I make
these silly faces at you Pisco when we talk, when I make these
silly faces at you, I am saying you're I am saying you for asking
me this question. I am saying you stupid piece of shit." That's
why I make the silly face. That's particularly insulting for
Pisco who had to sit through Hutch making these faces at him
consistently and Hutch is literally saying, "Well, I actually
the the correct answer is make a silly face." That
>> So obvious? >> way. Well, it's a layup if you're
not a politician and you don't need to worry about being composed
cuz you would just look at Crystal with a silly face and be like,
"What the [__] are you talking about?" But she had
to like pause and >> Dude, there's no
He said it. He actually said it. He actually said it. >> Composed
herself and then explain really basic concepts like adversaries
versus allies. Like we would never in a million years >> I
think Crystal's question is is is sort of questioning that Israel
should be an ally of America as it is currently >> I I
get that point, but there's a better way to to do that. >> I
I think she's saying, "So what I would guess is This is my guess
on the progression of the questioning and I really should just
watch it so I stop guessing. But I'm guessing that when they
say, "Hey, we shouldn't provide Iron Dome to Israel, right?"
Well, they go, "No, that's That would just be punishing the civilians
of Israel and we just want to protect civilian life." And the
core the correlation or sorry, the the corresponding goes, "Well,
why wouldn't we do that for Iran or Russia if it's just about
protecting civilians? Well, we don't want to go after their civilians
either." And it's almost like, "Well, when you provide that defense
for the civilian population, that actually shields the government
from the the disdain of the population
from committing acts of war with other places, right? That if
your population is unprotected and they have to they have to
actually withstand the effects or the the responses from the
other countries around them, then well everybody's mad. Everybody's
like, "No, no, no. Stop going to war. Be nicer."
Right? Diplomacy has a better chance of flourishing when you
don't have a literal shield preventing you from any reprisal.
It changes the calculus of the country who's doing the aggressive
actions because they now are insulated from the aggressive actions.
That's not to say that you should just always cut off that that
like you have to cut off Iron Dome funding. That That's not what
I would say it means. It's just saying that it is something that
enables offensive action. So, if you're just saying, "Well, it's
only about protecting citizens." No, it's not. It's not just
that. There's There's something else that happens there. >> Then
and they eventually did get to that question. And they started
to kind of dive into what that is. But they're asking questions
like, "What do we get out of a relationship with Israel?" Which
is like >> Okay. All right. I think at this point I do
want to switch over and check out this Lock In interview. We
don't have to watch the whole thing, but we can watch this part,
right? >> over the Biden administration policy. And as
you can tell, I'm very upset over the Trump administration policy.
>> So, let's deal not in straw men, but me and you here.
>> of what So, the tools that I have, the tools that we
have in general. To me, the most important thing is a pressurized
campaign to get aid into people who are starving. That to me
is num- the number one cuz that's the one is urgent and today.
And >> So, but will you cut off aid to Israel so long as
they're committing crimes against humanity? >> I There
is a difference between
uh a weapon to protect a country >> Hold it. I told you.
I told you that was the way it was going to go. I've not seen
this interview, never seen it before in my life. Okay? It's so
obvious that this is the direction the conversation has to like
go through. And it's so obvious why the questions proceed in
the way they do. Like it's incredibly obvious to me. >> country
from incoming missiles versus other type Offensive and defensive
weapons are different. So, >> you support offensive weapons
banned? Like would you stop any offensive aid to >> That
certainly to me would be a place to look, but I'm not going to
cut off a blanket next sale on a defensive weapon >> I
also I also reject that because for example, if Senator Hawkin,
if you were asked to support defensive weapons for
defensive weapons for Russia, you wouldn't back that. >> No,
but Iran I mean but >> They're defensive. They're just
protecting civilians, right? So how is it different? >> Because
Israel's being shot at.
>> No way. Oh, that's a great answer. The difference is
Israel's being shot at. Well, that's Hold on. Hold on.
>> They're just protecting civilians, right? So how is
it different? >> Because Israel's being shot at. >> is
Iran. So is Russia. >> Ukraine's shooting at Russia right
now. >> I I'm I I'm sorry. [clears throat] This is the
difference between allies, partners, and adversaries. >> it
an ally then? What what what are they doing right now that just
makes it an ally to you? >> I think allied relationships,
just like Lithuania right now, like the an allied relationship
or a partner relationship is a long-standing
relationship of
information sharing and diplomacy.
And it that is >> They're not an ally. Israel flips between
being an ally and being a peer
If Israel is an ally, if they are a peer, stop providing aid
to them. If they are a client, then exert influence. Do not flip
back and forth between the two and say they're a client 50% of
the time and that they're some peer 50% of the time because it
will make you look deranged, okay? No aid for peer nations, or
if they're like a client who requires your aid, who needs your
aid, who is consistently had your aid, additional funding over
a ton of other countries over throughout the West, right? Does
Does Canada get anywhere near Well, actually I don't I'm pretty
sure they don't get anywhere near the aid that Israel does. Pretty
confident. They're like I would imagine there's maybe, you know,
some discounts in buying weapons or something, possibly.
But it's like, dude, you can't flip back and forth. You you can't.
You cannot flip back and forth. If they are a client who gets
aid, who's reliant on you in some way for a security guarantee,
then they should listen for when matters of your own national
security or your own economic concerns come up. But they don't.
They don't at all, and that's the problem. >> Information
sharing and diplomacy.
And it that is to me, it's not a like every day we decide Lithuania
is our ally or not. We're allied or not. And sometimes we have
big breaks with allies. Right? Sometimes we have difficult moments
with allies. Sometimes it goes the wrong way with allies. But
an allied relationship is a long-term
>> it's hard it's hard for me to understand why we should
ally. Like I'm sure you believe in like our claims of >> Uh
how far Uh see you later, Kiriko. How far into
How far into Germany trying to take over Europe do you think
you would have remained allied with them for? Curious. If you
were allied with them hypothetically to start the war. >> to
believe in liberal human rights. Why would we would ally with
a nation that is committing a genocide and livestreaming it?
>> I ask literally, like this I think about this from the
mirror image way because I am not I do not support the things
that Donald Trump is doing, right? But I'm an So, do
I want other countries to look at America and be like, we don't
we can't stand Donald Trump. So, we're going to end any long-standing
relationship we have with the American people. We're going to
cut off any support we give them on information sharing.
>> Uh like, okay. This might be something you could look
at here. Now, this is not the same in any respect because America
is the global hegemon. So, trying to pretend that they're again
treating Israel like it's a peer and it should be treated like
a peer, which is very goofy. In In that case, if they're a peer,
they don't need ally they don't need aid. They don't need anything
like that. They can pay for all their right?
So, that's already bad, but
also the US is the global hegemon. So, all these other countries
sort of have to rely on the US in some way. And if you were to
say like, oh well, do I expect these countries to cut ties? No.
And Donald Trump there's a far better argument that Donald Trump
is some sort of transitory thing. I don't think it's true, by
the way. I think that's this level of populism's here to stay
in America, but there's a an argument that it's some kind of
transitory thing. And sorry, argument four would be that the
crimes of Donald Trump are still nowhere near anything what near
what Bibi Netanyahu is doing. They're not close. They're not
even a little bit close to Bibi Netanyahu, the Israeli government,
the Israeli nation. Not
And there was a fifth argument that I had, which was, oh, that
a lot of the a lot of the sort of like
non not necessarily peers, but the people who are in the security
groups with the United States, all the NATO members like this,
they're all looking at how they can decouple from the United
States now. So, yes, they are actually identifying and figuring
out ways to decouple themselves from a country who's acting in
a way that they can't stand. So, yes, they are immediately looking
into this. Donald Trump has started swing trying to trying to
use his baseball bat he's carrying around to swing at his allies,
and they've all gone, yeah, you know what? Screw a little bit.
Canada signs a trade deal with China. Bunch of other places are
starting to look around. Hey, who do we actually have relationships
with? Cuz America's not a very reliable partner right now. Anyway.
>> sharing or intelligence sharing. Like, we are not just
our elected leaders. And I think that's the thing that's been
>> Oh, god.
Oh, god.
But, unfortunately, in terms of the war crimes they're doing,
Israel is its elected leaders right now. These people all totally
support, are in lockstep, every leader would be making the exact
same foreign policy decisions the current Israeli administration
is making. There is no room for for disagreement on this in the
country, okay? So, there's tons of disagreement in America on
what Trump is doing, right? There's a ton of people who disagree
economically. Even in Trump's base, people will be mad about
the tariffs, people will be mad about inflation. There is no
universal
like like the support for the Iran war is probably like 30% or
something, like 25 to 30% I'm guessing at this point, okay?
The support for the Iran war within
is going to be insane. The support for broadly the continued
persecution of the Gaza campaign
is crazy. Like it's like and the people who, you know, if you
go and look at, hey, does the Israeli populace want, you know,
the Gazans to return to Gaza and start rebuilding there?
I don't think they broadly do.
It it's it's really rough when you start to look at how what
the level of support of the Israeli people for what their government
has done
in America what the support for
levels are for what the American government is doing. It's just
not the same at all. >> Do you in the conversation, so
B'Tselem >> Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, this is probably
the way you say it. Yes, it's the policy of Israel and it doesn't
matter that Netanyahu's the leader.
That is what Israel's going to continue to pursue. >> And
I think that's the thing that's been lost. Do you in the conversation,
so B'Tselem and another Israeli human rights organization joined
the global consensus, Amnesty International, some 800 scholars,
there was a piece from a Israeli scholar in the New York Times
in saying this is a genocide. Do you accept even Marjorie Taylor
Greene yesterday came out and said it was a genocide. Like, do
you accept that? And if you do, I mean, what responsibility
does a United States senator have? >> Okay, I'm I'm sorry.
As much as I understand that Crystal is pressing,
Crystal's so much more reserved than any description of this
interview led me to would be possible. Like she's so much more
reserved than I expected. Like she is not being aggressive, she's
not being like evil, she's not screaming over Elissa Slotkin.
This is actually way more reserved than I thought from the descriptions
I'd listened to. >> For this is a nation that, you know,
we send every year billions of dollars to aid to aid that you
have, you know, voted for and supported. Like what responsibility
does a United States Senator have to prevent genocide and to
stop genocide that we see ongoing? >> We have a responsibility
up till today
to ensure that food is getting in >> Is it a genocide?
I don't know that I'd use that term, but it is using the it is
violating the law of war. >> Why don't you use the term,
though? >> Because I think, you know, it's to me if it
is if do I think it's
>> Okay. All you need to say here, by the way, this is
a total get out of jail free card. You never have to answer this
question. You have a get out of jail free card, okay? Well, actually,
maybe you don't. Sorry, maybe you don't.
Oh, if you if you weren't approving US tax dollars for this,
you have a get out of jail free card cuz I think it's totally
fine for any politician anywhere to say, "I'm not going to judge
the domestic policy of another country because I am a leader
of this country and there are diplomatic there are diplomatic
um like consequences to a leader in one country criticizing another
country, right? You could get out of that. But then you keep
voting for aid to this country. So, unfortunately,
unfortunately, it's kind of rough. You look kind of bad when
you can't answer why you keep voting for aid to this country.
I think you shouldn't have to say I think you maybe get out of
the genocide question on that front. You'd say, "I I think that
has diplomatic, you know, there are diplomatic implications there
if I call it a genocide that I'm uncomfortable with. And I I
think it's important I withhold my personal opinion at this point
and continue to speak as a representative of the United States
of
>> Using it is violating the law of war. Why don't you
use the term though? >> Because I think, you know, it's
to me if it is if do I think it's ethnic cleansing,
which is what I think of in what genocide, I don't know if it
meets that definition. They're announcing it. >> you say
it earlier? >> Violating the law of war. >> you say?
>> Why don't you use the term though? >> Because
I think, you know, it's to me if it is if do I think it's ethnic
cleansing,
which is what I think of in what
>> Those are not the same thing. Those are not even close
to the same thing. It's definitely ethnic cleansing. You You
shouldn't even have that question anymore. I know this is 8 months
ago. It was definitely ethnic cleansing 8 months
Um they are doing ethnic cleansing now. Instead of just on two
fronts, now it's on three fronts. So, that's pretty cool. Ethnic
cleansing on three fronts at the same time.
they're they're officially juggling. It's not even just two balls
they're keeping in the air now. It's three. It's three ethnic
cleansings at the same time. Let's go.
W Israel? >> I don't know if it meets that definition.
They're announcing >> you say it earlier that it was ethnic
cleansing? You said that they wanted to force I mean, this is
open from the Israeli government. Like they're saying it. Their
minister >> national security. They come out and they're
like, we need we don't need shells. We don't need We need shells,
not food. And we need to encourage >> I I you >> You're
You're not going to get me to support what the Israeli government
is saying right now. I think the point I was trying to make is
it's not just about like we have relationships with nations over
time regardless of who their leaders are. We have really tough
moments. We have easier moments.
>> Um what government has not essentially been working
towards these same ends
for a long period of time? Which Israeli government was not working
towards this? You're going to go back to Rabin? What happened
to Rabin?
>> You're You're in the CIA. What happened to Yitzhak Rabin?
How did How did Yitzhak Rabin die?
>> But that doesn't I'm not willing to say >> that
like I hate everything ever in the >> Sure, but so even
even if you accept that they're committing a genocide, you still
wouldn't cut off their aid? >> I think that defensive aid
and offensive aid are different things and I think at this point
>> So it's not Nazi Germany every single >> Nazi
Germany is that we want defensive >> I mean it's just you
you have to see where they're all weapons that are being shipped.
You want another you >> Uh I think I think Crystal's not
good to She probably doesn't have my same argument, which is
too bad cuz I do think this is the argument. Uh maybe lefties
just weren't on this. I think I was in a private call a while
back and I was I was talking to somebody and I brought this up
that it's like, "Dude, you are insulating them from the consequences
of acting the way they do."
Right? Like Like if you
And ironically,
this person is like stabbing people and then people go to defend
themselves to hit back and you put a big shield up and then you
go, "Well, listen, offensive aid I'm not stabbing you, but like
offensive aid and defensive aid are
Well, no, they're not. No, they're not. They You are helping
them do this and you're continuing to push the society in that
direction because they can't see any of the consequences of the
things they do. And yes, in this case, the consequences I'm referring
to are rocket fire and missile fire from other countries that
you are preventing from hitting them. And perhaps if they were
facing the same consequences that people in Lebanon are facing
for Hezbollah and people in Iran are facing for the Iranian regime
and people in
anywhere around the Maybe if they could see some of the same
consequences, they would not be so quick to continuously bomb
all of their neighbors. >> I think that the the weapons
that they're using right now, I I to be honest, if you look at
what's happening on the ground, the military part of this conflict
is for the most part over. What they are doing What they are
doing every single day is around aid, and they are hurting people
around the delivery [clears throat] of >> No, they're also
going in at this point, 8 months ago. They're also going in and
setting up C4 charges and blowing up with no military objective
whatsoever, Alyssa. Setting C4 charges and detonating housing
in the area, reducing it to rubble.
In a systematic way. They're also getting ready to go back into
Gaza.
There new tunnels under the rubble or like what is happening
there? There's just new tunnels under the rubble. It wasn't enough
to reduce it all to
I I just got >> Same people who were trust try starving
people just trying to get aid. That is not high That's not high-intensity
bombs. That's not the weapons that you that we were talking about
2 years ago. It's just not. I'm sorry. Every single day the military
>> I Dude, I think people are sleeping on just how evil
the coordinated like time bombing is. I I think I think broadly,
and maybe it's because lefties are the people who are mostly
sharing this stuff, that like it somehow it it feels very lost
on
Like how is it How is it lost on people that we're facing a housing
crisis where we all live in the West? And you're watching their
housing be evaporated for nothing when there's no military
value to it. It's just to prevent these people from ever coming
back and having a way of life in that area. Like not only is
that ethnic cleansing, but it is is ethnic cleansing and preventing
their ability to ever rebuild there. It's It's ethnic cleansing.
It's destroying their capacity to ever be happy there, to build
like their lives. You're building up You're creating barriers
to them ever existing in that area again. Like it's It's not
enough to just call it ethnic cleansing. It's like unironically
like poisoning the wells.
Like this is their version. They're like, "Well, you know, we
got a lot of bad press for poisoning the wells. So, actually,
this is better. Destruction in part it's genocide. I I do think
yes. Yeah, like I think
Yeah, there's something about
I don't know why it just keeps coming back to me just this idea
of these guys laughing and like posing like actually posing in
a camera and shooting like Tik Tok shorts while stuff explodes
in the background. Like time detonations that are don't have
like a military
They are just destroying.
>> reports that I read, they are traditional
like this is a military that has a bad strategy. It is not the
bombs that we were seeing to
>> that you [clears throat] we were talking about 2 years
ago. It's just not. I'm sorry. Every single day of the military
reports that I read, they are traditional
like this is a military that has a bad strategy. It is not the
bombs that we were seeing 2 years ago. >> It's not a military
that has a bad strategy. The strategy is for starvation and ethnic
cleansing. That's their strategy and they're and they're accomplishing
it very effectively with the full backing of the United States
government including sadly Democrats. And so a couple more questions
that I know you have to >> Okay, this is a little more
forceful. I can see why people are like if you're just a straight
up blue no matter who Dem, I can see why this part you're like
okay, he's just talking over her. I By the way, I will say Crystal
Ball might have just saved Elissa Slotkin by talking over her.
Elissa Slotkin was about to say some totally insane that 8 months
ago you might have been able to get to fly, but if whatever she
was about to say right there that Crystal cut her off from saying,
if she'd been able to finish that sentence,
I think 8 months later today, that looks horrifying. Whatever
the she was about to say was going to be even more devastating
to what she's already said in this conversation. >> strategy.
It is not the bombs that >> It's it's a bad military with
a bad strategy so not the bombs we were seeing 2 years ago. Hey,
it's not that bad. 8 months ago it was it wasn't that bad guys.
It's not the same bombs we were seeing 2 years ago. >> seeing
2 years ago. [clears throat] >> a military that has a bad
strategy. The strategy is for starvation and ethnic
>> That's their strategy. >> That is not a That is
not a That is not a What was she going to say? What was she going
to say? Cuz she was about to say something insane that would
have looked so bad today. Slotkin comes off as more so uninformed
and I think that's worse than blatantly lying. That would be
possible
Fran, that would be possible that she's just uninformed and maybe
she's just speaking poorly. Except she literally said the opposite.
She literally said, "I read these military reports all the time."
Not a fact, not a famine, not a Yeah, I don't know. Not a I don't
know what she was going to say to be honest with you. She was
going to say something that was
But she she literally says she's informed. I see military reports
about what's going on there all the time. And it's a military
with a bad strategy. She's literally saying I'm informed. Not
fair, not fair, not a fair assessment.
>> energy. And they're And they're accomplishing it very
effectively with the full backing of the United States government
including sadly Democrats. >> And so I couple a couple
more questions and I know you have to to run. Um you know, I'm
I'm curious why you condemned Rashida Tlaib for using the rally
chant, you know, from the river to the sea. Something she said
for her evokes equal >> And you have not condemned Randy
Fine who said that Gau Zang should quote starve away, who floated
that the Gaza Strip should be nuked, who called Ilhan Omar and
Rashida Tlaib and so on um as well called them Muslim terrorist.
Where is the concern over >> condemning. I have no problem
condemning
uh Randy Fine who I don't know. I I don't know I'm sorry I don't
know who that person is. I have no problem condemning someone
who talks like that. >> Senator, we have to ask your last
question because the uh your staff is telling us. Do you think
AIPAC should register as a foreign lobby? >> I don't know
the answer to that. I think that I know plenty of people
um who think they should. >> Um you know, I I don't >> of
a cop-out answer, don't you think? >> I I mean, I I literally
I I just guess I'd have to look at the definition. I certainly
I certainly have had my tough moments with that organization.
And [clears throat] >> So, you stopped accepting their
funding? >> She did. >> You got to get You got to
get your facts straight. I have not >> Yeah, she did. She
did stop accepting their funding. On what grounds? Their their
their conduct in Gaza, no? No, they just kept donating to like
January 6th supporters.
It has nothing to do with Gaza or Israel's actions at all. Which
like that is a noble thing in and of itself, okay, that she doesn't
take donations from anybody who will support Jan- J6ers.
That's fine. That's good. But it doesn't have anything to do
with Israel actually, which is kind of weird. A total total boycott
on taking donations from AIPAC. But it has nothing to do with
Israel's actions. Very strange. >> endorsed by AIPAC. I
have not I I'm sorry. I was the first elected to the Senate that
was not endorsed by any group, AIPAC,
>> You've been the recipient of their >> In 2018
when I first ran, people who were members, yes. But I've not
been endorsed since then. And I I just got to be honest, like
uh I think that this is where facts really matter. It I've had
very very difficult conversations
with my colleagues in that organization,
um and made a choice back in 2021.
2021, so that was my the first time I was up for re-election.
So, I I understand that there's a sort of like again, cornered
position.
>> You can pull it back here a little bit. Looks a little
better. >> I call balls and strikes as someone who served
in the Middle East. >> I I do I have one more question
I have to ask you. Um
you know, we >> I'm just a neutral operator. As somebody
who served in the Middle East, I'm just a neutral operator. I
call balls and strikes. I don't know if I call it an ethnic cleansing,
though.
>> We do the show. I >> operator. Very cool. >> best
to try to uphold like, you know, basic human rights, Palestinian
humanity, oppose the killing of innocent civilians wherever that
happens. And I just want to tell you, like, I feel really guilty
that I'm not doing enough. I think all the time about I'm a mom.
I think all the time about those moms who can't feed their babies.
Those babies are starving. >> Uh if I had to agree with
the Dem type people, the more liberal types who say this is a
bad interview, this would be where like this is now
terrorism a little bit on her part. I do I do think this is like
in terms of professionalism,
the I I might agree with her entirely on the emotions, but this
is like borderline terrorism to do this, too. Like somebody's
coming on your show.
I I do think so. I think all the policy-based questions were
all totally fair. To do this and like have the catch in your
voice, that's rough. That's rough. >> to death. And I just
want to know, like, you're a United States senator. You did vote
for some of the bombs that were dropped on refugee camps. When
kids have been sniped in the head,
tents firebombed, people set on fire, the entire Gaza Strip turned
into
>> By the way, I I totally agree with Crystal on this.
I just think that
this is a rough one. I totally agree with her on the emotion,
on how you feel about it.
I think pressing on the opinions, getting those on the record
is very
This probably getting more emotional like this is going to prevent
other people from coming on the show. And I totally I would I
would never condemn her for getting emotional. I'm saying
I could see how this affects you professionally going forward.
But I think I think this probably
professionally helped her cuz I think their channel's like been
blowing up. Maybe not since that this, but their channel obviously
does very well. Clearly it wasn't a problem for any of their
viewers. I just totally get how
the more neolib types in terms of politicians wouldn't want to
come on the >> And now we're seeing these un-amazingly
bodies of babies starving to death every day. And I just I mean
>> And you're And you're for this. And you you you want
these babies, dude.
And by the way, I do believe this. I do believe that
Elissa Slotkin is in essence voting for this to continue happening.
Right? I do believe it. I don't I'm not saying Crystal's wrong.
I'm saying that just >> what you can do? >> Does
it eat you up? >> Does it eat you up? Do you think what
what more could I do? Do you regret any of your votes? Do you
regret any of your
A group of rabbis and Muslim community leaders came together
with a proposal that we are working on I'm just getting like
if we can't get other aid in at least get baby formula and nutritional
supplements for children in. Let that be kind of a green light,
never has a problem, no one's trying to eat baby formula other
than a baby, right? That is the proposal that I've been working
on all night and this morning. So in terms of what we're trying
to do, there's not a moment that goes by that this isn't something
that I'm working on and something that my own community, not
online, but my own community has practical things that they want
to do. They're willing to raise the money, they're willing to
buy the formula, they're willing to do whatever we need to do
to get it shipped in. That's how I spend my time. >> But
you're not willing to set off aid to >> To me, that to
me is the most effective thing that I can do today. >> This
is not a question. Your staff is telling us you absolutely have
to go. So we appreciate your time. Thank you very much for coming.
Thank you very much. Okay? Thank you guys so so for watching.
>> Yeah, I know. I see I see I
I see exactly what Hutz is talking about as a Rorschach test.
I think the thing for me is all of Slotkin's answers to the real
questions, the tangible questions, are all awful. Like horrible.
Like her her answers are god awful, okay? She didn't have a terrible
response at the end. So I can let her go. Well, I think
>> I think probably there's some like safe word that they
had that they were calling well, in the middle of somewhere in
the middle of Crystal like
I just think of all those mothers who can't feed their kids.
And then they're like, "Ah, banana banana banana banana stop
stop stop stop. You got to stop. Stop. You got to stop. You got
to stop." Anyway. Jesus Christ. Okay, we're uh we're back to
live and learn, okay? Now we've seen the interview. We've seen
like where it gets contentious talking about Israel. >> I
think Crystal's question is is sort of questioning that Israel
should be an ally of America. >> better way to I I get
>> that point, but there's a better way to to do that then
and they eventually did get to that question. And they started
to kind of dive into what that is. But they're asking questions
like what do we get out of a relationship with Israel, which
is like I mean, they cover geopolitics for a living. They should
understand like you can have a moral opposition to our like being
allied with Israel. I'm fine with questioning that. >> what's
wrong with the question then? If it's like easy to answer and
it's like, "Well, Israel's our ally and they should be our ally."
What's wrong Why is that like a gotcha question? Why is the question
wrong if there's just a very easy answer to it? The Is it because
Democrats shouldn't be questioned on >> Please go. No,
that's not what I'm saying. I You can question her on Israel,
but when you ask what Why would you You know, like if it's about
protecting civilians, why not give it to Iran? Well, well, like
if this is a highly top secret classified weapon
and we give it to Iran, they could theoretically repurpose it
and make it redundant. It's That is just like immediately that's
where your mind >> Yeah, but but like why shouldn't It
doesn't work for anyone. So like why would we ever cons-
>> get redundant. I mean,
>> Like if you want to make the point that we should we
should question our relationship with Israel. That's fine. >> But
I'm just saying like why is it a gotcha question if it's like
a very very simple easy answer and obvious? Like what's what's
wrong with the question? >> I don't think it was simple
or obvious like Krystal. I think she legitimately thought that
it was a slam dunk gotcha question that Slatkin [laughter] couldn't
like figure her way out of. But Slatkin like literally paused,
composed herself, and said,
>> Well, the the no, the issue is there shouldn't be any
problem with protecting allies. The the if you're if you're honing
in on like, "Oh, well, they could reverse engineer the technology."
That's obviously not the point of the question. You're you're
you're biting down at a point of the point of the question you're
biting down on some element of the question that is actually
getting you away from the moral argument of like obviously you
don't argue for less civilian casualties in a bunch of our adversary
states, right?
You don't do that. Anyway, we continue. >> We have allies,
we have adversaries, and we have strategic partners. And she
had to like explain this dynamic, which is just really this is
like really basic level geopolitical stuff. >> Well, if
it's really basic, why why is it a problem? Like if like if someone
asked me a really basic question, like look at Pete Buttigieg,
right? Pete Buttigieg just gets a really basic question about
inflation or is like with this guy on this whatever. I don't
even know what news I think it was. And he makes a really simple
set of like parameters, make the other guy look like a idiot.
I'm just like asking like why is that a problem if it's such
a loaded question or a question that's like requires just a basic
distillation of Why can't she use it to stun on Krystal? >> Yeah,
and and Hutch really quick cuz I want to give an example of what
he was talking about. Like have you seen like Bernie Sanders
on like Sacha Baron Cohen's like Who Is America?
>> Um it's been a while. It's been a while. That show was
crazy. >> Yeah, he's playing this like obese like southern
and he's like, "Why don't we put the 99% and put them in the
1%?" And Bernie is like, "But that's not how math works." Like,
you know, he doesn't uh like I the optically this looks not bad
for Bernie. Like he tries to make Bernie look stupid and Bernie's
like, "You're like essentially you're stupid." without saying
it. And Sorkin I think tried to do that, but like what I'm saying
is rhetorically and optically I don't think her answer looked
good even if she had the right idea. And that's all I got. >> falling
victim to the this Sorry, you haven't spoken in a while Dylan.
No, it's I I just wanted to say that. Personally, I want both
teams to lose.
I [laughter] I think I I think that number one,
uh going on Breaking Points is kind of like a Guantanamo Bay
torture tactic like that you can use against anyone. And so seeing
our political class have to deal uh with that program. I mean,
watching them interview Krystal was like watching like two monkeys
trying to like build a car. It was an impossible It was complete
[__] mess. I I can't watch Breaking Points without
one. >> Krystal Ball out of Illinois who ran for the ninth
district, right? >> Yeah, out of Illinois. Just just like
the questions they asked or when I hear like like Krystal just
make [__] up about wars. Like it's just it's like
she's just like winging it. Like when we gave Ukraine all the
jets, we never gave Ukraine jets. That's why they invaded Just
like random stuff. So I don't like them, but also I do want the
political class to be put in front of bad shows and bad >> Um
doesn't the US have to approve weapons transfers? And wasn't
that what Biden originally wouldn't approve of and then did eventually
approve of? Isn't that what they mean?
When when somebody says the US giving people jets, don't they
mean signing signing off on weapons transfers? Like it feels
like pretty obvious they don't mean literally giving them jets.
>> programs to deal with bad questions. If you're going
to run for president of the United States, you're going to be
in a a eventually where you're going to have some Fox News knuckle
dragger come in and say like if you support women why don't you
want to deport the migrant
You're going to >> you're going to you're going to get
that type of stuff and so I do think >> My my argument
My argument is that she did. She answered the question just fine.
Like she didn't lose her she didn't get triggered. She wasn't
the problem. She wasn't treating it like Pisco what are you doing
with me right now? Do you agree that that was a stupid question
or
>> I'm not sure what Wait wait it's >> stupid question
if if she's trying to get at why No I why we don't give Iran
the the Iron Dome. The reason >> Yeah this is this is actually
hold on. This is actually Hutch's
limitations. You know how we had the conversation about how like
realistically Hutch operating in the political world is like
essentially imagine a universe where all humans except for Hutch
have the capability to
And Hutch is grounded. And we've built the entire world around
Hutch to make it seem like we all just walk normally.
We to to not make him feel worse. And he doesn't understand that.
And so sometimes he gets really haughty with people when they're
like walking around with him and he he like jumps and he he's
like look look how much look how much better at jumping I am
than you. And other human beings really have like the capacity
for flight. He he literally can't fathom it. He doesn't understand
it. And so it's just his inability to understand what the meaning
of the question is what the point is. It's not literally like
hey why why don't we literally give the Iron Dome to these
It's it's meant to be a thought
>> Reason why I don't think it's a stupid question I'm
going to explain why is because it's clear that what she's really
getting at is questioning the notion that Iran is an ally and
that they should be treated as an enemy. And so it's I don't
really feel like there could be like a very easy What did I >> I
totally I I disagree with that. I don't think that's the point
of the question but well that shouldn't be the point of the question.
I now I to go back and listen again. I I felt like she was trying
to say obviously
protecting civilian lives. If all the Iron Dome is does is protect
civilian life, then why don't we give it to everybody? Because
then we can protect civilians everywhere. >> You're on.
Israel. My bad. It's Israel. So that's that's what the question
is getting at. >> Oh, no, that is the point. Hold on. That
that actually is the point. Never mind. I thought you were speaking
literally.
Yes, whether or not Israel should be an ally. Sorry. That is
that's more what she was getting at, yes. >> Wait, wait,
peace. I think you're also missing a point here, which is this
is in the context of AOC saying we need to sanction Israel, but
voting yes on Iron Dome funding because she says, "Hey, this
is strictly defensive." >> know what Wait, wait, no, she
didn't she didn't vote yes. >> Well, she voted or abstained
or whatever. The the point is she's making a distinction here
between the Iron Dome and every other weapons funding. And so
it's like, "Hey, if you're making a distinction or if some people
on the left make this distinction because they say this is going
to prevent civilian deaths and this isn't going to be used to
kill anyone, then why not send this as humanitarian
aid to other countries that are getting bombed? That's what >> Well,
no, I See, this is the argument.
I could see I could see exactly how this argument argument propagated,
okay?
I think I I think I had this this conversation with somebody
who probably talked to
So I pulled maybe. Maybe. But,
I don't think that's actually what she's doing cuz I thought
that going in, but I do think she's actually just saying you
should reevaluate whether or not Israel can be an ally. Like
is Israel truly an ally? And it is about like, "Hey, can we shouldn't
preventing
civilian death be like a a global perspective?" A little bit.
But it's less leaning into that than I thought it was in the
first place. >> getting at. And I I understand the argument
that they're making.
>> I I absolutely understand that and you can have a bunch
of reasons why the answer to it should be clear. But that doesn't
mean that the question itself is stupid if you're just trying
to elicit, well, it's not enough to say something's defensive,
right? There are other factors to consider such as whether it's
in America's strategic interest to be allied with it such a country.
And that will certainly turn that will I mean I am for example
in favor of cutting off all funding for Israel at this point
given how they're conducting themselves in this Iran war, to
say nothing of Gaza. Um and so I don't actually I don't think
it's like a it's so bad faith of a question. I think if it's
a if it's a stupid question, she should be able to answer. You
said that she answered it fine. What's the problem? >> If
you is it >> She did not answer it fine. She answered,
"But they're shooting at
>> That was the That was the answer. She did not answer
it fine. "Why should we give this to everybody?" "Well, they're
shooting at Israel."
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Yeah. Okay. >> The problem I think is that
I think what's happening right now is the
Party like the politicians, the actual elected politicians. They
all saw the same kind of like postmortems of 2024. They all saw
a resounding
assessment that that they they they ignored the alternative media
space. And obviously like we're seeing a ton more Democrats go
into these spaces. But what's happening is I think that their
staffers are scheduling them for interviews with people and they're
just now finding out just how rabidly like anti-Democratic Party
a lot of these spaces are. And so now
>> These spaces are not rabidly Krystal Ball is not rabidly
anti-Democratic Party. She's rabidly anti-genocide,
rabidly anti-starving a population to death, rabidly rabidly
anti-ethnic cleansing. If you've decided that you are going to
buy in and the Democrats are pro those things, then guess what?
You are going to have a rough time not just on Breaking Points,
but on on a lot of places in the alt media space.
Okay? It's just a fact. You cannot be pro those things, which
is being pro-Israel by the way. Being pro-Israel means in effect
being pro those things. And if you have a problem with that,
if you can't defend it, then off.
Don't go on these shows or don't run for Congress or vote differently.
Vote your
If you can't do any of these three things, then I I don't know
what to I don't even know what conversation we're having anymore.
You got to be one of those three. One of those three, okay? >> Now
it's creating these awkward situations like what you had with
Breaking Points and Slotkin. The problem is that she was going
for like this gotcha question. I mean, there was another part
There was like a couple other parts in the in the in the interview
where she basically asked her like, how do you sleep at night?
Like, how do you sleep at night with like a clear conscience?
[laughter] Or like
>> I will say
totally fair question in any conversation. I just thought, hey,
I get why people are like, oh, dude, bro, what
I I get it there a little bit. I
That's a little true. I thought it was
Hmm, how do I put this? If Elissa Slotkin was somebody who was
just a standard senator or whatever,
She was just a standard member of
Maybe. But she says she reads these military reports, and this
is just a military with a bad strategy. That was insane sweeping
that I think she should have actually been excoriated for, and
she didn't get excoriated. She didn't She didn't For some reason
it was disconnected. That That statement she made was so offensive
that I think she deserved basically everything that came after
that in the interview. It just happened to be delayed until the
end. That should have been, wait, you see what's happening there?
You have a good idea what's happening there? And you still won't
call it a genocide or an ethnic
Yeah, you're like, how do you sleep at night? Like, how do you
sleep at night? That's insane. That's an insane thing to
>> Like, she said at one point, you know, you said, you
know, you you care about like human rights or you say you care
about human rights. I mean, it was like she was skewering her.
And then just today or yesterday on Breaking Points, they posted
a video where they were reacting to >> I think these people
actually don't understand that going back to this
Like I'm I'm okay. I can I can put aside the emotionality and
say oh I can see why people who are sweeping for themselves don't
want to be on this show. I can see why they might like dislike
how
how Crystal handled it. To the average person, the average voter
Crystal looks better every day that goes by where Israel is still
a the ally of the United States. Crystal looks better. Crystal
looks more moral. Crystal looks
like she is the only sane person in the room. You cannot go back
and relitigate this conversation and say that Crystal looks worse
to anybody except for political operators who go well this looked
bad for us so therefore it's bad. This looks bad for my political
agenda therefore it is bad. That these are the only people and
you keep relitigating this conversation as if it's a conversation
you should be having,
Could you imagine a politician and I'm going to use the Holocaust
or the Nazis again? Could you imagine a politician who goes back
and in 19 like 40
Sorry uh let's say 1938 they're like harshly supporting Hitler.
And then in like 1944
they keep relitigating why they made statements that were pro-Hitler
and why it was a good decision to be pro-Hitler back then.
Right? Like like it's totally [__] insane that you
continue doing this. It's out of this world. Uh you missed part
earlier that plays into this. Earlier Slotkin said something
like there isn't anything I can do and Crystal responded you're
in Congress. If you can't, who can? That led to the emotions
at the end. I see. Well yeah we I timestamp came in after that.
My bad. But important to note, thank you. To Alyssa Slotkin having
a um town hall and then somebody asked her like hey so you take
you took 4.2 million dollars from the pro-Israel lobby. Like
what do you have to say about that? That number came from APAC
tracker and I don't know if you guys heard about all that controversy.
Did you guys hear about that? >> Yeah, like their methodology
seems like totally [__] >> Their methodology
is crazy. Like if it's it's it's an individual donor who at any
point has donated to a pro-Israel lob- lobby, they were counting
that in AIPAC tracker. And they were not a >> I don't think
that's a flawed methodology if you point it out.
I I think that's a totally fine methodology if you point out
that that's what you're doing.
I think anybody who's donated to AIPAC is going to be like a
Zionist and that's the whole point.
I don't think that's a flawed methodology at all. In fact, I
would love to see the person who is anti-Zionist who has taken
money from an individual donor
that also donated to AIPAC. If there's like a significant amount
of that, if that's where like 30% of the funding is, it's actually
going to anti-Zionist
and just somebody who was like, you know, a handful of billionaires
who donated to one thing that was AIPAC-funded or AIPAC-organized,
then maybe. But I do think that gives you a good idea. I don't
think that's flawed methodology. So long as they say that's what
the methodology is and they're not they don't hide it.
>> Applying that same standard >> consistently across
Yeah. >> Yeah, so it is insane. And Crystal Ball was like
promoting this kind of attack on Slotkin on her on her
>> promoting this kind of attack. Crystal didn't know Crystal
said, "Will you commit to not taking funds from them, right?"
I I could have sworn that was how she asked it. Maybe I mis-
Maybe I misremember, okay? Maybe I'm sweeping for Crystal right
now.
You've been the recipient of funds was back here.
Got to get your facts straight.
>> Um you know, I >> It's kind of a cop out. >> I
don't know the answer. >> Senator, we have to ask your
last question because the your staff is telling us. Do you think
AIPAC should register as a foreign lobby?
>> I don't know the answer. I think that I know plenty
of people um who think they should. Um you know, I I don't have
an answer I mean I literally I I just have to look at the definition.
I certainly I certainly have had my
>> So, will you stop accepting your phone? >> with
that organization >> And [clears throat] so, you stop accepting
their funding? >> You got to get You got to >> Yeah,
that is not I'm sorry, that's not co-signing an attack that says
$4 million or something. That is will you stop defending their
funding or whatever. And Alyssa Slotkin gets to say, "Well, I
haven't been taking money from them since the J6 shit."
I don't think that's I don't think that's co-signing an attack
at all.
In fact, I don't think I don't think Krystal has a good idea
of how much money she's taken at all. >> program. Like
to me >> Wait, is it like that kind of attack or AIPAC
tracker specifically cuz I did see Ryan Grim question the methodology
of
>> But she was she was legitimizing the question and she
was saying, "Well, she >> Like technically under AIPAC
tracker, the idea is is basically tracking Israeli influence
in politics, right? Like the the influence of Israel or pro-Israeli
people in politics. That's the point of AIPAC tracker. It is
not just to track AIPAC. It has to be to track like pro-Zionist
influence, right?
Well, if Larry Ellison starts his own thing and starts donating
money, the people who are trying to track AIPAC probably want
to include him in it
right? I don't think that's I don't think that's co-signing.
I think it's pretty obvious. >> to just have better answer
answers for these like legit questions. It wasn't a legit question.
>> Wait, wait, in what sense was it not a legit question?
I'm asking you, why is it not legit? >> I don't know if
you >> All right, sorry. I want to take a breath cuz I'm
I'm losing composure a little bit. >> I honestly hush.
Tell me if I'm wrong, but what you're saying is like this is
clearly like Krystal and Saagar coming in with this like very
anti-Democratic Party messaging Israel-Palestine question that
was like in what would otherwise be >> Literally, nobody
asked Soy Pill. Shut the [__] up. Nobody asked.
Let them
Holy [__] He's like trying to reduce the tension
and I want the tension. I want this to blow up. Come on, man.
>> saying is like this is clearly like Crystal and Saagar
coming in with this like very anti-Democratic Party messaging
Israel-Palestine question that was like in what would otherwise
be probably not like a super adversarial environment. Like, you
know, Pete's going on with a Republican, and he's expecting some
>> I'm sorry. If you if you have been voting or talking
in favor of Israel, and you go on Breaking Points, and you expect
an even-handed question or an even-handed like a back and forth
on Gaza, like a back and forth on Gaza where
it's like yeah, it's it's just obviously balanced, you're insane.
Your your staff too. And they would be Like, here's the thing.
The people who are actually in the wrong there are her staff.
I'm sorry, if you signed her up to go on Breaking Points, and
you don't know any of their positions, you are cuz I guarantee
you Breaking Points did at least some of the research on Elissa
Slotkin, had an idea of what questions they wanted to ask her.
The fact that she didn't want to do anything like that.
Apparently, Slotkin said she wanted to freeball it. I feel like
she probably didn't use the term freeball. Not a lot of Not a
lot of women out here saying they want to freeball it, okay?
I don't I don't feel like they got a good basis for making that
>> some sort of attacks, but like they're like all of a
sudden like, "Hey, bam, here's like a weird framing of this specific
issue, and why don't you have a perfect answer for this right
away?" Um it's it's like I don't know if you want to call it
clip >> Why don't they get a home run read on Breaking
Points then, right? Like, if if they want to get a hand job,
they come on Livin' Learn. But if they want to have the reporter
ask them questions, they go they go on Breaking Points. >> Martyn
Bailey. Martyn Bailey. Martyn >> No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Nobody's asking that.
>> Not What do you mean, Martyn Bailey? The [__]
are you talking about?
You mean You mean Martyn Bailey?
That's the whole point of going on Breaking Points. They have
opinions. They're going to ask questions. Unless your professor
is Young, and then Saagar will be thank you so much, sir. Thank
you for imparting your knowledge of the Jesuits to me, sir. Thank
you, sir. I appreciate you, sir. We'll talk to you later, sir.
>> We'll get to that later. I was asking if that was Hagar's
position. I don't I had to do is that what you're getting at
or >> Nobody's asking anybody to give politicians hand
jobs, but maybe don't like legitimize questions where the underlying
premise is entirely false and
Maybe don't do that.
Crystal said, will you accept will you stop accepting funding
from them? And Alyssa got to do her point.
It was It wasn't She didn't do some crazy attack. She didn't
say, your campaign is totally run by AIPAC. You're totally controlled
by AIPAC. She said, will you stop accepting funding from them?
Without even knowing, by the way, that implies it was not something
she researched. Cuz if she'd researched it, she would have certainly
come across the fact that Alyssa Slotkin stop accepting money
from AIPAC in 2021. So, it just sounds like she sort of threw
it out there like, would you commit to not take money from them?
Without knowing that she had already done so.
That that flies in the face of the idea that this was this whole
like gotcha question, gotcha concerted or sorry, gotcha research
attack. >> Wait, we haven't talked about Victor
>> That's huge and Dylan and Sara. >> Sure, I I talk
about Orban. I also have I did have a few things I didn't want
to talk to you guys specifically about that's in the news, but
I wanted to say just quickly before we move off this >> People
don't like Democrats. People hate Democrats right now. People
hate Democrats more than Republicans. That's what the polling
shows, right? It might not even with say just quickly before
we move off this topic. People don't like Democrats. People hate
Democrats right now. People Democrats more than Republicans.
That's what the polling shows, right? It might not even Republicans
in power, that's currently what the polling shows that more people
are dissatisfied with Democrats, but >> Sorry, I just I
had to I just had to watch IRAs that popped up. I just as Dylan
was saying that IRAs like, come on. Hey, come on, man. Hey, come
on, man. Hey, come on, man.